tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo in un nuovo
episodio di api e quindi ragazzuoli
siccome è un episodio un po speciale
questo visto che san valentino altro
ragazzi e l'episodio 90 quello del san
valentino che proprio il numero 90 di
amore non c'è proprio un cazzo se
intendete siccome ragazzi un episodio
speciale ho deciso di fare solo livelli
dedicati alla moore
quindi ragazzi adesso cercherò la
scritta love così il suo ep rissa e
quindi farò solo livelli d'amore primo
livello ragazzi la mamma voi pensate che
questo livello sia fatto per fare gli
auguri alla mamma e no in realtà è
perché io amo la madre di chi ha fatto
sto livello in di bello complimenti cioè
vero pieno di significato mi dicono se
dovrà essere tutti così magari no ai
ragazzi cambiamo un po lo sguardo trovo
questo qua mi sembra che avete un
concetto d'amore che non è proprio
veritiero ragazzi va bene che a poche
domande ognuno l'amore lo fa a modo suo
e quindi ecco perfetto no ma comunque i
tipi in alto a destra ragazzoni più
belle e fantastico sembra tipo do you
ringo bello del sito che ti stai
inglobati pa il suo dovresti caffè come
fa adesso anche voi donne potrete capire
che cosa si prova a farlo con un uomo
pieno di sangue ma quanto siete belli
voi la sua no no no vabbè ma non ce la
farò mai a prenderli tutti mi fate un
favore cascata e solo su quelli sotto
per cortesia no quella è troppo beslan
non cade giù fantastico non ce la farò
mai ragazzi a fine il suo livello ve lo
posso assicurare questo mi sono venuti
per l'amore ragazzi già fatta o ricava
nova perché se non si può mettere su
youtube
[Musica]
che ne pensi uk è piaciuta sta cosa non
gli ha fatto cagare sicuro dove raga
mancano gli ultimi due sono un
deficiente avete basta mi sono rotto le
palle
va bene così regala l'amore vince sempre
lo ama ama i cuori
sì però però non in questo senso di sé
quando io volevo dirti che ti avrei
donato il mio cuore intendevo
simbolicamente non così perché era già
così un po troppo tratto stiamo giocando
a calcetto con un cuore ragazzi
spiegatemi senso ecco quando gli dai il
tuo cuore glielo doni e loro lo
maltrattano approfittatrici di merda che
ha [ __ ] laida dando questa mi
chiamerà sentisse dura ancora 10 minuti
stacco a mia moglie
all arcobaleni no aspettate che c'era
c'è la frase intensa alla fine dobbiamo
leggerle l'amore è importante per il tuo
cuore
cazzo mi significa love aim high e
miglior band assist cufino ragazzi
finalmente un livello sull'amore decente
dio mio quello sarebbe cupido che devo
sparare mentre mentre si abbassa cosa ho
capito adesso presa perché michia la
tipa frena cagate un cuore spiegate
l'amore fa male ragazzi l'amore fa male
l'ho sempre detto io non mi senti e roma
è certo ci mancava solo questa come
grazie della pillola love story è mica
una storia d'amore dei 100 ragazzi
finalmente è tutto quanto cominciò con
un triangolo e poi dicono che gli
illuminati non esistono
va beh a parte gli illuminati che devo
saltare all'inizio c'è qualcuno che mi
spiega come si ama una persona
no questa non è una storia d'amore
questa è come farmi perdere del tempo
morale ragazzi l'amore fa male l'ho
detto anche prima è la stessa cosa love
story 2 no guarda io mi è passato il
primo conto tempo fa c'era un bambino
chiamato freddi che era odiato dai vabbè
non si sa perché odiato fregia che si
chiama freddi su tutti a giocare a
phinet freddy's ovviamente l'odio non
avrei mai amici serio l'idiota ma perché
le maestre non facevano nulla
le tombe tiger è vero che non tutti per
il culo ma poverino finché non incontrò
un amico chiamato bob tutti quanti mi
odiano lol
tutti quanti odiano anche meta che cazzo
di quelle nonno cia che ma perché non è
vero che odiano e a quel punto freddi
disse una cosa scioccante bob io ti amo
ma è un vecchio di merda un giorno loro
stanno stavano facendo è un bambino ma
cosa è un altro bambino li ha scoperti
ma perché dopo di che freddi e bob si
sposarono e freddi lasciò la scuola io
vi dichiaro vagabondo e bambino ho mica
è finita finalmente una ragazzi comunque
sia è stata una storia d'amore migliore
di twilight sicuramente bella
complimenti ma guarda sono proprio
curioso di vedere il sequel non posso
attendere oltre anzi ti prego fallo
uscire subito ama il tuo elmetto
fatemi capire quella minchia di casco è
composto da nokia 3310 per caso non
ditemelo perché se nobili hartung chiamo
ci mancava che non facevano un livello
sugli hard school che sul l'amore ci
mancava solo quello ma che succede che
riesca a morire al primo lo so io io io
lo so fare io ormai l'ho scritto o job
so già cosa succede in partenza mi fate
capire qual è l'utilità di steam i
chiari arti or sono tornato alla
partenza meglio di prima più in forma
soprattutto non ci fossero stati gli
arpioni sto gioco della minkia sarebbe
sarebbe stato più figo bello stai
facendo yoga zio fammi capire lo blend è
lei che bello no coppietta finalmente
che qui ecco niente ora il cuore quando
c'è di mezzo l'amore parte sempre a
[ __ ] niente non esiste volta in cui
non venga maltrattato sto povero cuore
inizia pazzia e il prete era stato
chiaro e finché morte non ci separi
fuori dai [ __ ] che adesso posso
andare a [ __ ] potevo perché non ho
più il pene però quello un altro
discorso ragazze possiamo fare senza
morire mica impossibilmente o no sono
morto io no no no non si fanno queste
cose con i cadaveri necrofilia
che schifo niente ragazzi sono scene
orrende basta non mi piaceva stiamo
appurando lega che l'amore series non
esiste cioè praticamente tutto sesso
lovely di no questa è carina perché
dovrebbe essere un pranzo romantico
siamo proprio sicuri che questo sia un
pranzo romantico perché c'è la tipa che
si sta mangiando un amico capito che se
continui a magna probabilmente esplodi
zia però ci hai una mina te ne sei resa
conto è sempre meglio di essere morti
per una mina
io non parlo c'è ma che cazzo per la
love valley stefan iraklis è la sorella
di harry potter questo non è amore ti
chiami anche stephanie sei una donna
come puoi concepire l'amore in questo
modo spiegano a meno che non sia vabbè
l'uomo che denuncia che talmente ubriaco
che sta palpandola schiena invece che le
tette una dama per me ce l'avete per
cortesia che sono un uomo solo io c'ho
federica come ecco così romantico
spiegami qualche cosa mi rappresenta sta
roba
questo è amore maledizione questo volevo
vedere che invece io entrerò tesoro ti
pago io tipo ho trovato ragazzi l'ho
trovata vieni tesoro che facciamo
facciamo all'amore vieni qua questo
chiedo non lo voglio il piede voglio
fare l'amore con te che cazzo se ti
piace questa cosa che stiamo facendo
l'ho vista fare da rocco adesso ti
faccio vedere una cosa più bella sei al
tesoro ti ho lasciata è perché mi sono
innamorata di questo pezzo di sedia p
pezzi di sedia sono il futuro to be
continued una guarda zio
preferirei che che credi rimanesse qui
il livello contento così vabbè
ragazzuoli vediamo se riesco a fare un
paio di livelli sul log fa vj
c'è qualcuno che mi ama a chi piace la
banana banana cosa mi trova scusate
banana trova il nono fermi by aziz
ciao aziz ringrazio aziz per aver fatto
il livello della banana trovo che bel
livello e come sono con te a io sono
morto come sono contento di fare i
livelli delle banane fiat di aziz sono
morto due volte la nava a casi perché
ecco bravo grazie a zisis a san
valentino invece di fare i miei livelli
alla fine faccio le banane non si sa
perché pare la swing hard dipende in che
senso hard prove quella ci sembra una
banana zio spiegami kilt e insegnato a
capire come sono fatte le banane perché
non sono fatte così le banane te lo dico
io
madonna cosa ho fatto porca eva che mira
schifosa e scusami se mi aggrappo alto
birillo tieni duro tieni duro che devo
tirarmi socio fatta da quella è una
banana un po più
vabbè
a varese non pensavo che un livello con
le banale potesse essere così violento
però poi ci sono i nomi dei livelli che
ti illustrano la fisica quantistica che
bello mi piace proprio che si chiama
così questo livello
mi sento un uomo migliore adesso banana
quiz qualche cazzo fa un quiz sulle
banane prima questo è un piccolo re una
banana gialla o rossa e gialla la banana
gialla che bravo che sono quanto giusto
dove crescono imparare ma le banane
crescono sugli alberi zio scusa mi stai
dicendo
perfetto mix 6 pisa banana a ricky forma
circolare o curva dipende zio se uno ci
hanno matranga tanto che sala può anche
attorciglia don banana state mesi il
test messing da o amico mio a chi non
piace la banana ma sei scemo chi droghi
non si droga chi ha fatto insomma come
domande più facili non facciamo banana
boat ora nell'ultimo banana che voglio
fare perché mi sembra doveroso
[Musica]
posso non dormire stasera no perché ciò
gli incubi già adesso va bene ci sono
delle banane proprio non troppo belle
mettiamola così schietto leva perché ci
hanno la faccia delle banane spiegato io
porca vacca come ho fatto a perdere
vabbè avete visto tutti o vino vinto
perché io sono più bello delle banane
perché vado ragazzi e questo che questo
era un video per san valentino
se state cercando di capire che cosa
aveva di san valentino questo video sto
cercando di capirlo anch'io spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi buon san
valentino a tutti buon san valentino a
me come giorno di san valentino
l'abbiamo passato per tipo dieci minuti
su e adesso dipende da dove state
guardando questo video
dovete attaccare la lingua o sul monitor
o sul cellulare ok limone con la tizia
facciamo prima quindi ragazzoni spero
che i video vi sia piaciuto poi san
valentino ancora o mi piace per la tipa
che passa valentino con la forchetta per
me che lo passo su e spero che viene vi
sia piaciuto ma senso che è piaciuto
argomento è un mi piace anche a pagina
di facebook e come invito a trattenere
iscrizione sono fischiate ci vediamo al
prossimo video ragazzi